all the things that are taking place at
Carnegie Mellon are just absolutely in
my opinion one of the most exciting
times of my life yeah I get goosebumps
standing up here because it's just such
an exciting time at Carnegie Mellon well
I can't imagine not being involved with
Carnegie Mellon I think that there's a
lot of things that are going on on
campus that alumni need to understand
and they need to know so I look at that
as part of my mission and I also look to
be able to bring more alumni back to the
campus so that they can see it and feel
it and touch it to every single time you
search for a job or every single time
you know someone who sees a little
kearney MO and alumni sticker on the
back of your car you're claiming it as
part of your community and in order to
continue being a part of that community
you need to you need to contribute to it
I'm a big advocate of getting back time
and volunteering time back to the school
I think it's importantly and I think it
gets a little contagious you don't have
to just sort of limit it to those four
years you really have a lifetime and I
think once you sort of make the first
step you can you can really get hot my
staff can tell when I have been on
Carnegie Mellon's campus because I'm 10
miles off the ground did you know that
you should have seen it I get so excited
we have some of the best students in the
country if you spend some time coming in
and talking to them there's a higher
chance that you'll be able to hire them
instead of you know the next big company
and so I think it's important for
everybody I am here largely because I
wish that they were more people like you
came
when I was in school when I was
struggling when I didn't have the
answers when I had questions but I could
relate to and you know I believe but you
should be the change you want to see and
one of my favorite things to see the
students recognize is that they're part
of a generational family when you wear
your sweatshirt in the airport as I do
that people go wow that's a really good
school and yes it is because generations
of people have come out of Carnegie
Mellon and done absolutely great things
all over the country all over the world
and so the students to currently
understand not just from the donor
support but also just their presence
their networking ability but the
students can really grow from that being
part of that family that name has to go
somewhere and has to represent something
it all starts in Pittsburgh and floats
throughout the world now the global
landscape has changed by what we do at
carnegie mellon on a daily basis what
you want a piece of that I don't care
how much time you give but every time
you do that you are impacting and
changing and improving the world I have
to be a part of that and I encourage
other alumni to be a part of that
you